à lord a dit vous êtes là pour les
pièces jaunes
eh bien ça va être l'occasion pour vous
de gagner des pièces chaudes
voilà je le dis de faire gagner des
pièces jaunes la production voilà on va
donner voilà de l'argent pour les pièces
jaunes c'est très simple vous allez
devoir faire trois combats il y aura un
premier combat alors c'était et nora qui
était prévu mais après a priori et nora
ne peut pas puisqu'elle est un petit peu
souffrante elle a une luxation donc et
nora ne le fera pas donc on va changer
c'est celui ou celle qui a le même
gabarit kenora c'est plus thierry moreau
dont thierry moreau david vous allez
avoir à 10 secondes pour mettre par
terre thierry moreau 15 secondes pour
mettre par terre tout fan autres dj et
le temps vous voudrez on va dire 20
secondes aller pour m mokhtar par terre
il y aura 50 euros pour thierry mot 100
euros pour te fasses 150 euros pour
mokhtar et à chaque fois bien sûr que
vous les mettrez par terre on donnera
donc les l'argent pour les pièces jaunes
veulent avec moi d'habitude
oui alors donc thierry moreau est là
donc ils en train de se faire à les y
parvenez thierry moreau donc 50 euros il
va se mettre donc sur le tatami est-ce
qu'on peut équiper s'il vous plaît david
douillet est ce qu'on peut mettre david
us couple et met également le kimono
merci très vite les chiffres noirs
merci
là elle alors ouais mais qu'est ce qui
se passe entre les deux mondes avec sa
bien c'est technique c'est tout mais
c'est vrai oui lui la lutte avait mis sa
cruze est ceinture jaune vous ça veut
dire la ceinture jaune c'est quoi c'est
une cata font tourner on sait le début
je vous concerne or en humour et les
ceintures jaunes aussi aller on peut en
jeu donc mais je ne l'aurais pas loin
c'est magique
alors allez-y donc on fait le salut oui
c'est comme ça c'est pas le salut
comment on dit déjà
voilà ce qu'a fait leo nucci matin où je
suis maman je viens d'y message est là
mais allez-y 10 secondes pour mettre par
terre thierry moreau sais pas
ça c'est fait ça s'est réglé merci merci
monsieur merci donc 50 euros donc pour
les pièces et l'intérim au rajout de 50
euros bravo tu chéris rajoute 50 euros
thierry moreau pieds jaunes ses fans
pièces jaunes attention qu'à seconde
maintenant et regarder david douillet il
remet même le tatami alors attention
cette fois notre dj les ceintures bleues
la tension est animé des coûts allée b
s'il vous plaît allez alors là là je me
permet de remettre le tatami il ya 100
euros
alors attention maintenant 150 euros nos
pièces jaunes et on va appeler motards
me déçoit pas sinon si c'est pas lui qui
va taper et où je vais te mettre en sang
après je le massacre bon il fait
attention 150 euros
genre
ses fans en 150 ans rue sur le corps
150 +59 s'attaque en plus en plus en 350
euros pour les plages au galop
bravo tu as bon alors david je retiens
deux choses de ces combats dix mois
alors la première chose eh bien j'ai un
poste pour vous ça vous dirai à mes
côtés ici et si l embrouille vous
intervenez vitamines avec plaisir c'est
fait donc ça c'est fait et deuxième est
david quand même c'est impressionnant
mais chante asie 12 est impressionnant
mon père on a vu mokhtar volée ça
régresse qu est ce que le réalisateur
peut leur montrer la séquence avec au
tard ce que mokhtar sait que c'est
quelqu'un que je joue voilà que
j'entraîne un petit peu quoi le
bravo